[Music]
Deadpool is about to make a comeback and
in the past few weeks news about the
highly anticipated MCU movie came thick
and fast originally Deadpool 3 was only
supposed to hit theaters in November
2024 but as it became known in early
June the premiere has now been brought
forward to May 3rd 2024. so it's about
time we took a closer look at the
current cast the story info and what's
going on behind the scenes enjoy our new
original
the cast surrounding the two Heroes
Deadpool and Wolverine is slowly but
surely falling into place in addition to
some X-Men representatives there are
also initial details about the villain
of the film
let's talk about the two starring rules
first it's clear of course that Ryan
Reynolds will return in the role of Wade
Wilson AKA Deadpool the actor was the
driving force behind the comic character
actually being brought to the big screen
and has absolutely shaped the character
with his humor the big hype around
Deadpool 3 already began with the
announcement of the film however because
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine one of the most
popular X-Men is making an unexpected
comeback on the big screen this is the
10th time the Australian has slipped
into the role of the mutant his story
was supposed to be over with the 2017
movie Logan the fact that he returns
anyway is thanks to Reynolds in the past
Reynolds has repeatedly urged Jackman to
shoot another movie together Reynolds
has given a lot of thought to how
Wolverine can show up in Deadpool
without breaking The Narrative of the
other films in an interview he revealed
how the character will be brought back
after dying in Logan thanks to
multiverses and Cable's time traveling
device stolen in Deadpool 2. there would
be several possibilities according to
Hugh Jackman the latter will be used
this way the plot of the Wolverine
movies and especially Logan would not be
ruined which is very important to him
however it is quite likely that this
will be the last film in which we'll be
able to see Wolverine there has been no
talk of a Deadpool 4 yet in any case it
is clear that as in the comics the two
do not like each other at all and only
work together very reluctantly we are
already looking forward to seeing how
much the two will regularly come to
blows a recently published photo of the
two Heroes on the set and in full
costume cause some excitement for the
first time we see Wolverine in his
classic yellow suit which makes
particularly fans of the comics rejoice
the X-Force is back in Deadpool 3 as
well the members of the X-Men spin-off
group were introduced in the second part
and brutally decimated again among them
is of course Colossus the man with steel
body has already broken the one or other
bone of Deadpool the character's voice
is once again spoken by Stefan capichek
Brianna Hildebrand and shioli kutsuna
return as negasonic teenage Warhead and
her girlfriend Yukio the contrasting
pair of a badass fighter armed with
nuclear powers and her rather sweet
ninja companion already made for some
laughs in the last film the most
important member of the X-Force and I'm
sure we can all agree on this is of
course Peter played by Rob Delaney he
stands out from the other members by the
utter lack of any superpowers or special
abilities in Deadpool 2 Peter
miraculously survives a parachute jump
while many of his colleagues lose their
lives spectacularly a short time later
however Peter accidentally ends up dying
during a rescue attempt when he comes
into contact with a toxic substance at
the end of the movie though this is
undone by Deadpool's time travel Delaney
has already signed his car contract for
the third part so we can look forward to
his comeback but there will also be one
loss in the Deadpool 3 cast ZZ Bates
revealed during an interview that she
will not return to the role of domino
nevertheless she is looking forward to
the new movie just like we are
by Deadpool's side will once again be
his beloved Vanessa played by Morena
Baccarin likewise a key member of his
closest allies is the cab driver
dopinder played by Karen Sony another
fan favorite who will also ensure some
laughs in Deadpool 3. in addition we can
again look forward to verbal duels
between Deadpool and blind Al as Leslie
ugam says already agreed to join the new
film
in February deadline reported the
signing of Emma Corin for the role of
the antagonist in Deadpool 3. she was
already impressive as lady die in
Netflix's the crown sadly it is not
known yet which precise role corn will
take on according to rumors the star
could assume the role of the Sorceress
spiral she was originally captured in
the comics by Mojo who was hinted at in
Deadpool 2 and later banished to Earth
in the comics she later becomes a part
of the X-Force and even sides with her
former adversary Deadpool another
potential character making the rounds on
the web is Lady Death she personifies
death and has the ability to manipulate
time and reality in the comics she also
has a special bond with Deadpool and
Thanos the latter in particular is
hopelessly in love with her however she
finds Deadpool more attractive since he
is Immortal and thus Lady Death has zero
chance of obtaining his soul her
affection for Deadpool could make for
some funny moments in the film however
these are all just speculations and
rumors but we believe that the team will
surely find a suitable role for her in
the Marvel Universe for corn herself
Deadpool 3 could mean the fight final
breakthrough in the ranks of the big
Hollywood movies provided she can
convince the audience of her Talent
back in November 2022 there were the
first signs on Twitter that the third
part of Deadpool might have a connection
to the Disney plus series Loki at the
time The Lovable character missed
minutes from Loki tweeted a greeting to
Deadpool to which Ryan Reynolds also
promptly responded after that things got
quiet about the rumor until Owen Wilson
was confirmed for the cast in March 2023
Wilson last played the role of agent
Mobius of the time variance Authority in
the Loki series it is not 100 clear
whether Wilson will also play this
character in Deadpool 3. the information
comes from Insider Source Jeff Snyder
however and he has already proven to be
extremely reliable in the past we will
probably first learn more about mobius's
future in season 2 of the Loki series
which will be released on Disney Plus on
October 6 2023
according to the latest information
another character is set to make a
return to the big screen in Deadpool 3
that nobody really expected Jennifer
Garner will be making an appearance as
Elektra she first played the female
assassin in the 2003 Daredevil movie
starring Ben Affleck although the comic
adaptation flopped her solo spin-off
Elektra followed two years later which
also failed to be a success the fact
that she is now unexpectedly back in the
role after 19 years speaks for both the
typical humor of the Deadpool series and
for a story about the Multiverse
the specific plot of Deadpool 3 remains
a big secret but the clues so far
already give an interesting impression
the movie is part of the MCU for the
first time so the Multiverse could play
a bigger role and above all provide an
explanation for the appearance of
Wolverine in this context it would also
open the door for Loki Mobius and the
TVA both Lady Death and spiral would fit
into the setting both characters are
sorceresses and well versed in the
Multiverse their abilities to manipulate
space and time may be the Catalyst for
Wolverine's appearance in Deadpool's
world the other X-Men may not even know
Wolverine here so he might not be able
to rely on their support Hugh Jackman
has already confirmed that there will be
a fight between Logan and Deadpool at
the beginning of the film including a
fair amount of Destruction The Logical
Next Step would then be for the two to
form an involuntary team to take on the
villain whoever that ends up being in
the case of spiral there's even the
possibility that she too will end up
siding with Deadpool just like in the
comics that would no doubt be a nice
happy ending for everyone even if it
doesn't sound quite like the brutal dead
pool we know him to be
the R rating is equally as important for
a Deadpool movie as a crazy and
spectacular Story the previous movies in
20th century Fox's Deadpool series stood
out for their hardcore action and dark
humor all of them were given the
infamous R rating which means the films
were not suitable for miners after
Disney took over Fox many fans feared
that Deadpool would face some sort of
censorship after all Disney is known for
a rather wanting to appeal to the
largest possible audience however the
big relief for adult action fans came
with a statement from Disney boss Bob
Iger and Marvel president Kevin feige
both confirmed that they would not stray
from the violence and humor of the
predecessors in the third installment
this would mean that Deadpool 3 will be
the first R-rated MCU movie so fans can
heave a sigh of relief and look forward
to Deadpool maintaining his uncensored
and offbeat style in the MCU
let's take a look behind the scenes of
Deadpool 3. in fact for a long time it
was not sure whether they'll even be a
Deadpool sequel under Disney and if so
whether it will take place in the MCU
then in December 2019 Ryan Reynolds
personally revealed a third Deadpool
movie was in the works with the full
team at Marvel Studios in October 2020
the active search for additional
screenwriters began which ended with the
signing of Wendy Molino and Lizzy Molino
Logan they were later replaced by Rhett
Rhys and Paul wernick were responsible
for the current version of the script
with the constant involvement of Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool 3 is directed by Sean
Levy the 54 year old Canadian has
previously directed movies such as free
guy the atom project and Night at the
Museum and was also a part of stranger
things in addition to Kevin feige Ryan
Reynolds who was actively involved in
many of the behind the scenes processes
is also working as a producer filming
began on May 22nd 2023 in London and
Pinewood Studios in buckinghamshire
under the working title tidal wave and
another location is set to be Vancouver
the current writers strike in the U.S
did not get in the way of the start of
shooting for the time being as the
script has already been completed
however one drawback remains due to the
strike not a single line of the script
may be changed on set a major problem
for Ryan Reynolds and the team who
usually tend to improvise a lot in order
to find the best gags we sincerely hope
that Deadpool will still maintain its
signature jokes the theatrical release
of Deadpool 3 was recently rescheduled
by several months and will now take
place earlier than expected on May 3rd
2024. we thus hoped for a first Deadpool
3 teaser trailer at the d23 Expo in
September which will then of course also
be available here on our Channel
this was all the info about the third
part of Deadpool for us Deadpool and
Wolverine are a great enhancement to the
MCU and we hope that this won't be their
last appearance what do you guys think
do the characters fit into the MCU or
should they rather be doing their own
thing let us know your opinion and ideas
for Deadpool 3 in the comments and if
you like the video we'd be happy to get
your thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you foreign